hello everyone i'm alana and we have
uh some news first
i changed my setup
breaking news i know another is actually
details in this video that will be
interesting how cool is this
it's a pedestal it lights up
like i can
like change stuff on it
dude
it's so cool we're going to leave it
like about there no maybe about there
amazing they built a bookcase into it oh
my gosh so that i don't have to have my
big kratos and atreya statues on the
ground i'll make a separate video about
that but wow how cool is that very very
happy with it
my background is slowly coming together
um no first actual bit of news is
something i'm super excited about
so uh comedy podcast that i do here on
youtube.com charlatazard and patreon.com
charlanazad called idiots
brainbrook called idiots and abroad
which uh i do with john smith jacob
fullerton and rahul colley it's a show
where the four of us really talk about
anything we want but we try to center it
in traveling
or just like kind of the experiences we
have
uh being people from very different
places with very different backgrounds
who
go between very different places it's
mostly a comedy show though where we
just get up to shenanigans and the next
episode will publish next monday
publishes on the first monday of every
month patreon will get it early and they
will also get generally like an extended
cut and some extra content as well if
you want to support on there it's how
we're able to run the show um but we are
doing the show for the first time
live
in person
in front of an audience
i'm so so stoked about this we are doing
it in la let me pull up the link to give
you guys the details
i go here idiots and abroad live
and then
it's here
just everybody ignore this pretend that
i had this prepared ahead of time as i
should have
if you could all just pretend
that i definitely already had the link
up and that you didn't have to watch me
scramble to get the link right now
that would be very comforting thank you
boom wow look how quick i was amazing
you know what i'm going to edit
everything out
except for them
so march 12th a very normal podcast tour
with the funhouse podcast and idiots and
abroad um for reference
we are not actually touring
we're just in la which is obviously very
exciting
so
the fun house podcast will host a live
episode at the globe theater with
special guest podcast idiots and abroad
that is us date and time is saturday
march 12 2022
6 30 p.m pst
for those of you wondering because
you've seen me talk about the fact that
i am
hosting
the second year of the
video game award show that i created
on this same date
you are correct
and i'm very excited about that too so
my morning will be
getting the set to host the
second video game accessibility awards
please tune in we are also found out
that's part of this news that we are
live on twitch.tv
twitch we'll be on the front page of
twitch but it'll also be on my
personal twitch um if you prefer a
slightly more chill chat that is the
best place to find it um
and then i have to go run off to the
globe theater to do a live podcast
in front of hopefully a whole bunch of
you beautiful people um but we'll get
into a bit more of that so
just pull this back down again
we are the special guest podcast idiots
and abroad who will be joining the
funhouse crew so i guess this is who
will be on the fun house podcast and
then this is obviously idiots and abroad
um we're all gonna be there which is
awesome we weren't sure
if everybody would be able to make it
but um we are uh hopefully nobody has to
pull out because obviously rahul has a
pretty busy schedule especially not that
jacob and john don't you know obviously
super everybody's super busy
just such busy people
uh
yeah this is pretty much
a slightly outdated description of our
show the show is all about four friends
catching up on living in vastly
different countries we all live in the
same country now but you get the idea
so we're gonna do the show live for
an hour i believe um i have an
announcement to make when we're
doing it that i'm pretty excited about
that hopefully pans out okay
so ticket info they have vip tickets for
75 silver tickets which i have some to
give away stay tuned and bronze tickets
um oh alcoholic drinks will be available
don't mind if i do
thank you so i'll leave a link in the
description below or you can just search
a very normal podcast to uh or probably
fun house podcast or idiots and abroad
on eventbrite
and you will probably be able to find
that pretty easily
um
so yeah we i can't speak for fun house i
don't know what they're planning to do
but for idiots and abroad because the
show is funded by patreon
it didn't feel right to
sell tickets for this and then
not let the patrons have the episodes so
uh whatever we do live will be up on
patreon exclusively i imagine that that
fun house will probably distribute
theirs differently but uh for anyone who
can't make it in person yeah we will be
up on
um patreon is where i'm gonna publish
the the audio just for those people who
are supporting us but couldn't make it
in person because they live in vastly
different places however if you are in
la
tickets i have four i believe silver
tickets to give away so what we're going
to do here is
tell me
in a hundred words or less
and i'm going to give you a cutoff of
sunday the 6th of march so not very long
um 100 words or less before sunday the
6th of march at 7 p.m pacific time i
don't know
let's make it midnight because i'm not
going to read them on sunday i'm going
to read them on monday so okay that's
fine
uh 100 words or less tell me what is
your favorite moment
from idiots and abroad
and why
you will also need to leave in the
comment which you'll leave below you
will also need to leave a way for me to
contact you
uh generally instagram or twitter is my
best suggestion so that i can send you a
dm and let you know that you've won and
connect you with the ticketing team to
make sure that you can pick up your
tickets
um
and i guess say if you want a plus one
as well probably put down plus one so
it's 100
answering the question
and then it is
your instagram or your twitter handle
with dms open make sure you're looking
at them
and then it's just put plus one if you
want to plus one or no plus one um and i
will do my best to to get in touch with
you next week uh otherwise of course
because we don't have a whole lot of
tickets to give away i believe we have
four
um check out the event right by tickets
come say hi i'm really excited about it
yeah we're like i said i think recording
for an hour and then it'll go up on
patreon but
i haven't done something like this in
person in front of
like real human internet people for a
really long time and it's always very
nice because it's like the internet can
be so terrible sometimes
and when you get to do stuff like this
in person it's it's so nice to like see
people's faces the faces behind some of
the nice comments that you do get and it
just kind of reminds you that
people are nice
so it's been almost hard during the
pandemic like
dealing with internet toxicity crap when
not seeing people in person so i'm
excited about it um i believe that it is
vaccinated on the event but i don't want
to speak to any of that
let me confirm
okay they have it listed here so i will
speak to it performers to provide full
proof of vaccination which is fine for
us yeah so it's all staff patrons and
performers provide
proof of full vaccination two weeks up
to final dose and sorry or proof of a
negative test
um you have to show your vaccination
card or a negative test when you arrive
at the door for entry additionally moss
will be worn by staff at all times and
will be required of all attendees when
not eating or drinking
so uh vaccinated masks
be safe
of course so yeah i'm really excited
about it i hope that we can see you
there
i don't know what else to stick it's
great it's gonna be fun
um
hopefully we can do more of these at
different venues or different places and
um
keep having a fun time making this very
silly show that we make so the second
piece of news jumping off of that
is the video game accessibility awards
has announced
presenters um
so yeah if you don't know what that show
is basically i've been working on it for
two years and this is the second year i
created it uh in 2020 because i wanted
to try to encourage more game
development studios to get involved in
making games more accessible was the
plan essentially
so
um
the idea behind the show is highlight
games that do a really good job of
making games more accessible for
disabled gamers specifically
all kinds of disabilities of course and
um we've got our categories have been
announced our nominees have been
announced and we just announced our
presenters or just about to announce our
presenters tomorrow when the time this
goes up and i'm just going to say one
ahead of time because it's really
exciting
ryan reynolds
that's not a joke
ryan reynolds is one of our presenters
how wild is that ryan reynolds is
presenting an award
at the video game award show that i
created and am now co-running with my
very good friend slash one of my best
friend steve spahn who's my partner in
crime who is the reason ryan is involved
that's that was all steve
how cool is that uh we have a whole
bunch of really cool presenters and i
think the show's gonna be really fun so
please tune in to both which are on the
same day
the video game sex ability awards is
march 12th 2 p.m pacific time twitch.tv
slash twitch or you can go to twitch.tv
slash carolina charlana's i can't even
say my own username which related
sorry that i haven't been um streaming
lately i just absolutely haven't had the
time i've been very
burnt out in a whole bunch of ways so
hoping to get back to it soon hopefully
today um
i just i i hope so i'm not positive i
might fall asleep i'm module i'm gonna
try
um keep raising money for black girls
code and raise some money for ukraine as
well um i'll leave a link in the
description to both of those if you'd
like to help out by donating as well but
yeah sorry about that yeah i hate is my
12 month partner anniversary this month
so very big thank you to everybody who
has supported my journey on twitch even
if i haven't streamed in 30 days that's
my bad but we will be for the video game
accessibility awards and it is really a
thing that you can do that can help is
just tune in it should be funny and
informative uh you'll you'll go away
learning stuff
um
and have a good time and getting views
is what's going to make it easier to
make a bigger better show next year
because it's easier to get sponsors if
we can improve those views so that's all
i need you to do i don't need you to
give us any money i don't need to do
anything for us i just need you to tune
in
ask other people to tune in if you're a
streamer we'd love it if you would host
the stream
um help us get the word out to get
people to watch it
and to have a fun time watching it to
come learn about accessibility
from two people who care about it very
deeply and uh
are fun maybe i don't know
but i'm having a a hell of a time um
organizing the show with steve he's
wonderful to work with so
those are the things that i wanted to
cover
mostly wanted to make sure that i let
you guys know about the giveaway
and the fact that idiots and abroad is
live in l.a
come say hi i promise i have legs
there's there's a whole body below the
cutoff thing you see on a webcam it's
a whole person i promise i'm not
attached to this cyberpunk chair oh look
at the little dog tail
hello
sleepy lady no she is passed out i will
not wake her uh all right that is it
today everybody i hope you guys have a
good one i'll see you guys next time bye